police have arrested a man on suspicion
of murder after two young girls aged
three and one were killed in a fire in
Nottingham investigators say the blaze
was started deliberately officers are
appealing for anyone who was in the area
at the time and might have seen
something to come forward Becky Johnson
reports from Nottingham a warning there
are some flashing lights from the start
I just woke up in the early hours of the
morning to see this firefighters trying
to stop the smoke that was billowing
from the first floor flat
people watched in horror as they
realized two children were inside
neighbors they first they saw
firefighters carrying out the
three-year-old girl before an emergency
worker emerged cradling the one-year-old
the children were taken over the road
where paramedics tried to resuscitate
them before they went by ambulance to
hospital
their lives couldn't be saved their
mother who was also rescued from the
flat remains critically ill in hospital
by morning the blackened windows were
the only outward sign of the terror they
must have felt inside on this quiet
street in Clifton in Nottingham people
were told to stay indoors
and then came news that police believed
the fire wasn't an accident
31 year old local man has been arrested
on suspicion of murder and attempted
murder he remains in custody
the fire took hold of the first floor of
the property and neighboring properties
were evacuated two children were treated
at the scene for smoke inhalation but
unfortunately despite bester efforts
they passed away at hospital this
morning a woman also within the property
was taken to Queen's Medical Center
where she remains in a critical
condition
forensic investigations will likely take
some time officers have taken away
potential evidence for examination
Sadness the loss of life compounded by
shock that someone could have done this
deliberately
Becky Johnson Sky News Nottingham